moderate beer consumption lowers your
risk of heart attack by 25 to 40 logs
instagram has some controversial medical
information on it but facebook is known
to be the home to medical conspiracies
so let's check out these health posts
and give a huge thank you to thrive
market for sponsoring this video and
these sweet potato chips the best
breakfast for you based on your zodiac
sign this is a meme right like this is
not a Facebook helpful a Gemini should
eat raisin bran Ali oh it looks like
like a wrap from Dunkin Donuts this is
absolutely ridonculous health benefits
of dance boosts memory improved
flexibility reduced stress increased
anxiety improved balance and posture
okay look is dance gonna boost your
memory probably not is it gonna improve
flexibility probably because you've got
to keep your hips moving anytime you go
through a wide range of motion you're
gonna Boop improve flexibility are you
gonna reduce stress yeah cuz it's
awesome to dance are you gonna increase
energy yeah because you're exercising
you can improve balance and posture yeah
cuz look at these moves
I actually took some dance classes at
the beginning of this year and they got
shut down because of Kovac my dance
moves are awful because of kovat and I'm
sticking with that statement how to calm
a crying baby in one minute oh I like
these pressure points will help to relax
them I'm scared where this is going head
and teeth wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
it says head slash teeth and then
they're pressing on the babies too okay
I don't know what's going on in this
video it already seems highly inaccurate
chest and in the foot life is oh wait
I'm so confused
don't listen if a baby's crying and you
need to figure out what could be going
wrong are they hungry how they wet
themselves is there a part of their body
that's bothering them and if you've
checked all those things and you think
your baby's alright you shouldn't really
try and move the baby around I want to
tell you about my long-term partner
thrive market it's an online marketplace
that makes healthy eating and healthy
shopping affordable they have
twenty-five to fifty percent off retail
prices they have home goods beauty
products food what I love is when you go
on their website you can actually sort
it by the things that are important to
you values diets for example if you're
following keto click keto paleo paleo
cruelty-free it's there and during kovat
it's really convenient to have all these
things delivered right to your home I've
used it for a really long time and I've
been recommending it for you guys as
well there's all sorts of membership
options for me the 12-month package at
five dollars a month is the no-brainer
to select they have a money back
guarantee option and their warehouses
are zero waste so it's not only good for
you it's also good for the environment
you can run on one some people are born
with just one kidney and live healthy
lives
can you live with one kidney absolutely
in fact I know people who have donated a
kidney to their loved one or compatible
match hold on I believe Selena Gomez
received a kidney from one of her
friends but you have to take really
cautious steps once you only have one
kidney you really need to make sure
you're well hydrated you're not taking
medications that could potentially harm
your one kidney because you are at
higher risk for certain medical problems
obviously because you don't have a
backup kidney miracle cure I already
love the name of this page because we
all need a miracle cure doesn't exist
what we all need try these sleeping
positions to improve your health well
why is it say try these sleeping
positions when it says two out of three
of those are wrong and only one of them
is right I don't like that sleeping
position that much I mean for certain
people it might be comfortable keeping
your arms like that elevated above your
head can really cause some impingement
issues especially around your rotator
cuff your rotator cuff is made up of
four muscles that attach to your
shoulder really give it fine motor
control this is the infraspinatus
supraspinatus terry's minor and
subscapularis sometimes that one gets
stuck in my head when you have them in
this position that can sometimes put
pressure there decreased circulation you
wake up sort of with a dead arm I'm not
a huge fan of that position laying on
the side is fine laying on the back is
fine if you have the right pillow and
mattress combination ideally you want to
have a firm enough bed where you have
support so your back doesn't completely
collapse but not so firm that it puts
pressure on you as a side sleeper into
your shoulder because that could also be
quite uncomfortable a little pro tip
here depending on how much you weigh
will also play a role in the firmness
that you experience from a mattress if I
as someone who's 200 plus pounds lay on
a medium mattress I might find it too
soft because I'm heavier then if let's
say my sister who's like 120 pounds
lays on that same mattress to always
test them out if you have the option
seven things about your tongue color can
reveal about your health stick out your
tongue for a quick health checkup before
we start know that these videos are
almost never accurate because there's
variations to human color variations to
organs and there could be normal
anatomical variations that this thing
can take into consideration so it's
bound to make huge generalizations which
end up inaccurate but let's see how
inaccurate light-pink
you are healthy and they painted the
tongue the color of a neon highlighter
if your tongue is the color of an pink
neon highlighter you're a cartoon
because I don't think I've ever seen
that in a human body
whoa what a jump from pink if your
tongue is red you might be suffering
from an infectious disease this is the
definition of healthcare-associated
health information associated
xiety this is where we always make the
joke you go on WebMD you find out you
have cancer this is the problem the fact
that this says your tongue is red it
means you have an infectious disease
this would scare the life out of me if
your tongue is a color that you're not
used to seeing talk to your doctor about
it do not assume you have an infectious
disease because honestly I look at my
tongue and say that it's red right now
and I don't have an infectious disease I
promise this is why beer is healthy whoa
whoa whoa beer increases bone density
beer as a high concentration of silicon
which helps to bind muscle and bone
tissue together it increases bone mass
not a hundred percent certain about
silicon whether it helps bind muscle and
bone tissue together but I will say that
whatever ingredient in beer helps you
have strong bones can most definitely be
gotten from other sources without the
need for alcohol so already I'm gonna
say this is moderate beer consumption
lowers your risk of heart attack by 25
to 40 lies they probably found an awful
poor quality uncontrolled study and
they're trying to draw conclusions from
it this is absolutely not true in fact
the studies that we've used in the past
to say that there is some benefit to
drinking alcohols usually came from
studies related to wine consumption not
beer in fact heavy drinking increases
the risk of heart disease alcohol is
actually cardio toxic to the chambers of
your heart the muscles of your heart it
could actually call cause dilated
cardiomyopathy where your heart becomes
so enlarged that it's floppy and doesn't
work well in pumping blood throughout
your body enjoying a beer also helps
increase the amount of healthy HDL
cholesterol in your body no it does not
lower your cholesterol drinking beer
often will increase your cholesterol
level overall and cause more problems
leading to plaque formation which is why
having a high cholesterol is worse so no
beer is not a solution for any of these
problems thus far whenever I give advice
about alcohol my advice is always if you
don't need it don't use it because
there's no real proven benefit from it
if you do use it make sure you use it in
the smallest amounts possible that if
there is a potential benefit you're
maximizing that and minimizing the harms
top 9 benefits of grounding oh this is
my buddy Mercola did you know that the
energy from the earth can help you live
a healthier life yeah
like if you go out into the Sun your
body can create vitamin D improve sleep
quality and promotes feelings of
restfulness upon waking now I know this
whole time my patients have been
struggling with sleep I should have just
told them to go out for a walk on grass
without their shoes on reduces muscle
stiffness and soreness I mean these
claims are just ridiculous at least give
me how that could happen like are you
gonna make a stretch and say there's an
electrical charge leaving my body and it
becomes one with the earth and that
makes my muscles relax like come on like
we have to be reasonable I'm gonna
summarize this video for you
without lying this is the honest version
of this video Hey
go outside and go for a walk in nature
and I guarantee you because you're
happier because you're less stressed
breathing fresh air you're seeing green
all around you which is actually more
pleasing to the eye you're gonna feel
more relaxed you're gonna have better
health outcomes overall you can keep
your shoes on or take them off whatever
is most comfortable for you and I don't
need to promise you anything cuz overall
it's a healthy thing oh the best
hangover cure just so you know a
hangover is usually oversimplified when
we think about it hey Laura's us all
sort of different symptoms and
simultaneous things are happening within
your body dehydration alcohol
intoxication diarrhea nausea gastritis
in the stomach all these things are
happening simultaneously so hangover is
really a combination a confluence of
symptoms if you will if anyone knows how
to cure a hangover it would be a ship um
know if anyone would know how to cure a
hangover it would be a scientist two
ingredients ice two parts Fernan and one
part what my man solution to hangover is
to drink more alcohol yeah if you're
having alcohol withdrawal it will ease
your withdrawal symptoms but that is not
a cure by any means tastes like a minty
pinecone you know what sometimes I do
wake up in the morning I'm like I wish I
had a minty pinecone taste in my mouth
right now how is that pleasurable
braking courts discreetly confirm MMR
vaccine causes no it doesn't and that's
not what the court confirmed in fact
just today there was a a medical article
published from the Journal of American
Medical so
they looked at five countries two
million participants they found 22,000
of them who are diagnosed with autism
which is one in ninety and they found
that 80% of the autism cases were
inherited that means not due to
vaccinations or anything external that's
so important to talk about because those
who are anti vaccine will hijack some of
this misinformation and try and convince
you of their points to scare you away
from vaccines unnecessarily this is
about the truth and if we're trying to
do the best for our patients we can't
just go off of unproven hypotheses and
theories you need to look at the
evidence there's been a study of 600,000
children who have been vaccinated no
link with autism found this study with
millions of people finding that autism
80% of the time is mainly inherited
these are important things to look at
please do not fall for the
misinformation that comes from a lot of
these natural sources on Facebook this
is probably the worst form of
misinformation on Facebook check out
these hilarious tic TOCs
or this awesome video I do with my
nephews recently we also got to give a
huge thank you once again to thrive
market for sponsoring this video I just
placed my order and I can't wait to get
it you should too
links down below stay happy and healthy
[Music]